wenn wir über china sprechen werden wir
auch irgendwann zumindest über den
ursprung dieser krise sprechen müssen
nämlich darüber wie das corona virus
überhaupt entstehen konnte
wenn wir jetzt sehen dass dort weiterhin
diese fisch märkte gibt stellen sich
viele menschen die frage musste die
internationale gemeinschaft nicht
irgendwann druck auf china machen um zu
sagen wir wollen kein verzehr von
fledermaus suppen schlangen hunden und
katzen mehr
also ich bin wirtschaftsminister und ich
bin jurist
ich bin kein mediziner aber ich habe
eines gelernt dass eine epidemie die in
einem land beginnt sehr schnell zu einer
weltweiten globalen pandemie werden
können wir haben beim ausbruch von ebola
vor fünf jahren ist erfolgreich
vermeiden können das ebola von afrika
nach europa übergeschwappt ist aber das
hängt auch damit zusammen dass die
volkswirtschaften zwischen afrika und
europa nicht so verflochten sind wie
zwischen asien und europa und deshalb
ist die frage wie geht man in dem einen
land damit um
und wie in dem anderen nicht nur eine
frage des nationalen interesses aber ich
will auch darauf hinweisen dass es
überhaupt gar keinen grund für
nationalen hochmut gibt viele haben
gesagt so etwas wie in china könnte uns
nicht passieren und dann haben wir
festgestellt dass die zahl der
infektionen auch in den usa und in
europa sehr stark zugenommen hat und
dass es einzelne länder gibt die bei den
zahl der todesopfer china überholt haben
und das zeigt wir sitzen eigentlich alle
in einem boot und deshalb setze ich
darauf dass wir im rahmen von g 20 das
sind die 20 wichtigsten länder dieser
welt ist auch deutschland mit dabei dass
wir in diesem rahmen auch darüber reden
gibt es mindeststandards für solchen und
epidemie prävention also verhinderung
gibt es bestimmte informationspflichten
die man verschärfen muss gegenüber
anderen ländern
denn wir haben gesehen dass viren vor
grenzen nicht halt machen und dass wir
deshalb auch eine gemeinsame
verantwortung tragen für ihren machen
vor grenzen nicht halt sie sagen es aber
noch einmal ganz konkret finden sie das
fledermaus socken zum beispiel verboten
werden sollten also druck auf china dass
das nicht
angeboten hatte also ich habe in meinem
leben noch keine fledermäuse gegessen
ich glaube auch nicht dass das noch mal
passieren wird aber und das möchte ich
hinzufügen noch einmal epidemiologische
ratschläge im einzelnen sind sache der
zuständigen mediziner wir haben die
weltgesundheitsorganisation wir haben
das robert koch institut in deutschland
das hervorragende arbeit macht und ich
würde mir wünschen dass über diese
fragen dort diskutiert und entschieden
glauben sie dass china bereit ist zu
diskutieren haben sie das signale auch
dabei als ich habe als
wirtschaftsminister in den letzten
beiden jahren sehr gute persönliche
beziehungen aufgebaut zu meinen partnern
in china
das sind drei oder vier unterschiedliche
minister wir haben regelmäßige gespräche
und ich werde mich in diesem rahmen auch
dafür einsetzen und ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass auch die jedenfalls die
junge generation von
entscheidungsträgern in china genau weiß
dass es eine gemeinsame internationale
verantwortung gibt und diese debatte
müssen wir so führen dass niemand von
einem hohen moralischen ross glaubt dem
anderen ratschläge zu geben
aber dass wir gemeinsam die frage
stellen was ist falsch gemacht worden
was muss besser laufen und was müssen
wir verändern